what's up everybody welcome back to my
youtube channel richard on data if
you're new here my name is richard and
this is the channel where we talk about
data data science statistics and
programming subscribe for all kinds of
content just like this and hit the
notification bell so you never miss an
update this is my data science
statistics tutorial series where I give
you all the statistics knowledge that
you need to conquer the data science
world in statistics there are certain
distributions that you absolutely need
to know random variables are distributed
in particular ways and those
distributions provide us very easy very
useful convenient frameworks for
modeling real world activities now there
are more distributions out there that I
can possibly hope to count and I'm not
saying you need to know every single one
of them but there are certain ones which
show up everywhere and they're
absolutely critical to understand the
normal distribution is hands-down the
most important and most common
distribution in all of statistics and
part of that is because of what's known
as the central limit theorem which
essentially tells us that a lot of
activities which are repeated over and
over again can be modeled using a normal
distribution but that's a different
topic for a different day additionally a
ton of statistical tests out there
assume at least from a theoretical
standpoint that something follows a
normal distribution
just some properties about the normal
distribution first and foremost it is
used for modeling continuous data only
not discrete data as I talked about in
my video on mean median and mode the
normal distribution is nice in the sense
that all of those metrics mean median
and mode are equal to each other also
the normal distribution is completely
defined by two parameters that's the
mean often denoted by the symbol mu and
the variance often denoted by Sigma
squared or alternatively the standard
deviation which is
by Sigma then there's what's known as
the empirical rule which says that when
you have a normal distribution 68% of
your values are within one standard
deviation of the mean
95% of values are within two standard
deviations of the mean
and then ninety-nine point seven percent
of values are within three standard
deviations of the mean also associated
with the normal distribution is one
super important metric and that's known
as the z-score also sometimes referred
to as the standardized score now these
sounds super fancy but they're not a
z-score is just the number of standard
deviations that a measurement is away
from the mean now you don't need to have
a normal distribution in order to
calculate this and in fact these show up
in context other than a normal
distribution but the normal distribution
does give these very nice and useful
properties as we'll see in a minute here
we're gonna work through a couple
examples here and you'll see how simple
and easy it is to use the normal
distribution to do it you need a normal
probability table also if you know how
to program an R or Python you can use
that instead most graphing calculators
or scientific calculators have this
functionality built in but when you're
just getting started it is easier to use
a normal probability table at first the
link to this one will be in the
description but you can find these all
over the Internet it is important to
know how to read these and this will
make most sense when you see an example
but let's start with just one case so on
the left side here you have the digit in
the ones place and from left to right at
the top you have the digit in the second
place that is your z-score and then the
numbers on the inside of the table are
the area to the left of each of those
z-scores so what does that mean well
let's take the value for a z-score of
one point zero zero for example we look
in the table that area is 0.8 4 1 3 now
this means if you have a z-score of 1
you are in the 84 point
three percentile of all such
measurements now putting that another
way the chance that some randomly
selected measurement is less than that
is eighty four point one three percent
all right let's look at a real world
example so there's a study out there
which tells us that baby birth weight is
normally distributed that the mean of
all such baby birth weights is seven
point three pounds and the standard
deviation is one point three pounds
additionally we know that a baby born at
less than five point five pounds is
considered low birth weight so we're
gonna ask two questions number one
what's the chance that a baby is born at
low birth weight that is what's the
probability that a baby is born at less
than five point five pounds and then
number two how heavy does a baby need to
be to be in the 95th percentile of birth
weight so for both of these questions
we're going to make use of our z-score
formula Z equals X minus mu over Sigma
and this basically again this just tells
us how far our measurement is away from
the mean in standard deviations in our
first question what's the probability
that a baby is born with less than 5.5
pounds at birth weight we start by
calculating the z-score at 5.5 pounds so
we do the math here we end up with a Z
equal to negative one point three eight
now this tells us that a baby that's
born with that birth weight is at one
point three eight standard deviations
under the mean now we have to go to our
normal probability table we're going to
look up Z equals negative one point
three eight and we find that the area to
the left of that point is point zero
eight three eight well we're done
that is our answer the probability that
a randomly selected baby weighs less
than 5.5 pounds at birth is point zero
eight three eight that is eight point
three eight percent and then our
question about the 95th percentile of
baby birth why
how heavy does the baby need to be to be
in the 95th percentile that's a very
similar question we just have to do some
of the math in Reverse so we're actually
going to start with our normal
probability table and we're going to
look for the z-score corresponding the
closest to an area to the left of 0.95
so you're going to look down your table
and you're gonna see that the closest
z-scores to that are one point six four
and one point six five now in this case
it doesn't really really matter which
one you pick I like to take the average
of the two to get the absolute closest
estimate so we're going to start with a
z-score of 1.645 that's the z-score you
need to be in the 95th percentile then
we just solve for the measurement we
have 1.645
equals x minus 7.3 over 1.3 we solved
for the measurement we have to be at
nine point four pounds to be in the 95th
percentile here
now that you've seen a couple examples
and hopefully you get the idea of how to
work with a normal distribution and
z-scores and how simple it really is
just one last thing to point out we've
been working this whole time with a
normal distribution where the mean is
seven point three and the standard
deviation is one point three let's say
you took every data point in that
distribution and you subtracted the mean
and you divided by the standard
deviation well you would actually arrive
at a distribution where the mean is 0
and the standard deviation is 1 and
that's actually the foundation for the
normal probability table working in the
first place
a z-score is distributed normally with a
mean of 0 and a standard deviation of 1
this is actually the foundation for
what's called a Z test which is what's
going on in the background of tons of
statistical hypothesis tests out there
once you understand z-scores you're that
much closer to understanding how more
complex statistical tests work running
them and then knowing exactly what their
conclusions are telling you also when
you're doing more complex exercises like
modeling is
scores can be very helpful and useful
inputs to the model rather than using
the raw variables themselves so just a
thing to keep in mind so thanks
everybody for watching this video if you
found it helpful smash the like button
and then I'll see you all next time
until then richard on data